well hundreds of people in Port Sudan
have demonstrated against what they call
foreign interference in the weeks-long
fighting they're demanding the expulsion
of the emirati ambassador to Sudan and
the U.N a special representative accused
them of supporting the paramilitary
rapid support forces
and the U.N Secretary General Antonio
Gutierrez has called for an end to the
fighting in Sudan he warns violence is
creating a humanitarian catastrophe
rahila Muhammad has more of the people
trying to flee
after weeks of being stranded and caught
up in the fighting in Sudan these
Nigerian citizens have finally made it
home most of them are students they were
evacuated by military plane overnight to
Abuja they're relieved to have escaped
the violence
which was very scary it even shakes the
houses
it was very scary it's just romantic
others say they had to wait at the Egypt
Sudan border for days with no option but
to sleep on the streets until help
arrived a lot of challenges
and
and I know once my enemies to experience
what we saw let's talk about our loved
ones
they joined hundreds of thousands of
others trying to flee Sudan after the
fight scene began between the Army and
the powerful rapid support forces
instability is pushing more families to
leave their homes dozens of buses are
lining up every day with evacuees
looking to cross into Egypt by ferry
and drivers are risking their lives
trying to get people to safety each long
journey involves hours of waiting in
crowded and hot conditions
people there are tired they are sleeping
on the streets in the mosques and
schools we get them to ride the macrobus
and leave early in the morning like 7
A.M we leave from the Sudanese border
where they get their travel procedures
done and this takes time
Aid groups including the UN are urging
Sudan's warring factions to guarantee
safe passage of much needed relief
supplies hospitals are at breaking point
and there's a severe shortage of basic
necessities the conflict is worsening
and already dire humanitarian situation
with tens of thousands of refugees
arriving in neighboring countries like
Chad
for people who have left Sudan it's a
moment of relief
but for those still caught in the middle
it's a desperate situation that's
getting worse by the day rahila Muhammad
Al Jazeera
well Sapphire is a Sudanese resident
here in Doha and she was in hot tune
with her family when the fighting began
and she joined us in the studio earlier
and told us about the journey out of the
city
and in the route we saw
we saw so much conflict we saw
dead bodies we saw
people that were lost
carrying everything that they owned on
on a rucksack
and we saw Armed Forces
I learned things I never thought I
should learn I learned that you should
put up mattresses by the window
to soften the blow of a bomb so when the
glass shakes it doesn't hurt you
I learned the different sounds
of machinery
I learned the sounds of what fighter
jets sound like and the timing it takes
for a bomb to drop
I would count all of these things as I
would lay on the floor
just praying that a stray bullet didn't
hit our window
we did run out of water at one point
because electricity was cut water was
one of the water pipes got shot by stray
bullet um and I made the decision with
my cousin to go grab water from a nearby
store that was still opening providing
Services through the back door and we
were shot out
it was incredibly risky to even
step outside your door
safety barbecue with her story well
hundreds of people from Sudan continue
to arrive in the Saudi Arabian city of
Jeddah Let's cross now to Russell certa
who's following the evacuation efforts
there and Russell tell us what's
happening
well now foreign
countries including turkey and Syria and
also European countries such as long as
such as Northern Denmark so terms of the
countries so the Internationals are now
own that ship and trying to come
together
expecting them to be here so you can see
that here the planting a force are
underway to welcome and to shelter them
you can see see that the ambulances are
here we have seen the medical teams are
mentioned their final preparations to
receive is
higher the people because in the other
side of the sea so the the direct
support forces the parability
Army which were supposed to protect
Sudanese people are now fighting each
other and there are thousands of people
who are caught in that close by and now
around 2 000 of them are about to arrive
here but today there has been also
another medical issue a ship which
anchored in the Islamic corporate
more than 200 people not only about 63
of them were American Nationals like the
rest when the foreign
why the hotel and also they are going to
be provided with a one to my one month
residence visa as well so we are going
to be provided for a good shelter as
well however after that it's on Premiere
what's going to happen to them because
it's the case of the people because
they're coming here now they're talking
about thousands but that number is
expect of fear to to to to to to pass
overseas there's more than tens of the
thousands and then it's going to get a
serious price however here is all the
officials talking to their quite
concerned they have to say that and it
rises
is quite important that's why they're
very much
all right Russell back with you as a
chip arrives and people begin to
disembark it thanks very much indeed in
the meantime